وبالحديث عن الازمات الاسود لم ياتي بعد
والعام 2023 قد يكون احد اكثر الاعوام
تحديا منذ عقود لان المشهد العالمي يظل
اكثر تقلبا وغموضا من اي وقت مضى في
التاريخ الحديث تقول هنا مجلات ذا ناشونال
الانترست الامريكيه التي سردت بالتفصيل
اخطار العام الحاليه المجله تحدثت عن حاله
الركود التي وقعت في المملكه المتحده
ورجحت ان يكون الركود في الولايات المتحده
اقصر واقل مما هو عليه في اوروبا التي
تتعرض للضغوط بسبب قربها الجغرافيا من
الصراع في اوكرانيا واعتمادها التقليدي
على الطاقه بشكل مباشر من روسيا اما احوال
الصين بمجرد ان تتكيف مع كورونا خلال عام
20320 سوف ينتعش اقتصادها من جديد
الاقتصاد الصيني ربما ايضا يؤدي الى
ارتفاع التضخم في الاقتصادات الغربيه طبعا
بحسب المجله بسبب تدهور الاوضاع في
اوكرانيا والمرجحه ان تزداد سوءا في
الاسابيع والاشهر المقبله كون روسيا تستعد
لشنه هجوم كبير في النصف الاول من عام
2023 بعدما جندت اكثر من 200,000 شخص جديد
في الاشهر التي سبقت نهايه العام 2022 اما
الديون المتصاعده في الاسواق الناشئه
فاصبحت غير مستدامه الى حد كبير ودول عده
ربما تتعثر خلال عام 2023 فتحصل سنه ذلك
سلسله من حالات التخلف عن سداد الديون
السياديه لاسيه طبعا في افريقيا ما لم
تطلق جهود اعاده او تطلق جهود اعاده هيكله
منسقه وفعاله المجال الامريكيه اعتبرت انه
خلال العام 2023 ستظل التوترات بين
الولايات المتحده والصين مرتفعه بشكل خطير
على جبهات عده لاسيه ما حول تايوان وبحر
الصين
[موسيقى]